hello everyone and welcome to round
fifteen of the 1936 international
tournament in Moscow here Emmanuel
Lasker wood white pieces faces his old
nemesis josé raúl capablanca now
Capablanca is still on the field this is
round 15 so he's having an excellent
tournament and now he has an opportunity
to do something with the black pieces
against the manual Lasker before we
check it out I have a very interesting
photo challenge so best of luck to Ruben
who are who are the two people in the
photo one point for each person so best
of luck to everyone and by two people I
mean the two people that are playing
chess so there it is but as it is a very
old photo I do have a newer one so here
it is these are the same two people but
this is a you know a fresh photo taken
taken this year
and it's very interesting I don't know
if they're actually playing this game or
are they trying to recreate it as here
you can see that the person on the left
is holding a piece up in the air and
here also you can see the person who
left holding a piece the person on the
right has the wristwatch on his left on
his left wrist also it's the same in
this photo and the the pose pretty much
is the same between both players so very
nice except in this photo the player on
the left has the white pieces and in
this photo a player on the left has the
black pieces so if this is a real game
this could be the first game they played
since this game so it could be a rematch
but as we don't have access to any of
those games we I don't think we'll ever
learn the score so mr. luck to everyone
let's check out this game Alaska has the
white pieces and he opens with E 4 and
capablanca - a very nice surprise place
to c5 so the Sicilian defense Knight to
f3 Knight to c6
we have d4 a break in the center seek
after snide captures in the knight to f6
Knight to c3 d6 and they're now Bishop
to e2 we have Bishop to d7 Bishop to e3
and now II 6 Queen d2 we have a six and
now f4 Queen to c7 and here Knights the
b3
if you're ever in a situation like this
you never want to capture for example
here because after B captures black just
gonna have an extremely strong Center
he's gonna have a semi-open B file for
the rook already and you're gonna really
limit your King to where it wants to go
you're probably never gonna Castle
queenside anymore as you just opened up
black's rook so you're gonna have to go
King side and if black already knows
where you're gonna go so he's gonna
transfer all of his game there so here
nice to be three avoiding the exchange
we have b4 b5 by capablanca and Bishop
to f3 rook to b8 guarding the b-pawn as
kappa blanka wants to push a 5 and then
b4 or a 4 we had nice to eat 2 and now
Bishop to e7
we have castles castles and here comes
Knight 2 G 3 and a 5 as as planned kappa
blanka
says that she's not really interested in
anything that's going on and the King
said that the real ideas are on the
Queen side we have Knight back to d4 and
now comes a 4 rook a to e1 and rook F to
c8 now really going going for ideas on
the Queen side here if this night ever
moves the seat upon will come under
attack so last for defends it up front
rook to f2 and now comes Knight the e8
knife to e8 with ideas of defending the
g7 pawn if white ever manages to create
an attack against la king and also this
f1 is now free I have to be pushed
forward we have Knight captures on c6
Bishop captures on c6 and now f5 Lasker
starts his attack on the under King side
and here you of course you don't want to
capture an f5 Knight captures which give
this night a beautiful square where it
would be very strong
so instead after f5 simply closing the
position with E 5 we have 90 to h5 now
threatening ideas like f6 we have Queen
to b7 as Alaska is no longer defending
the e4 pawn with the night and now
Capablanca uses this to create an attack
against the e4 pawn push up to g5 now
opening up
defense from the rukon e1 and also
offering a trade of bishops here you can
exchange and then after Queen comes play
f6 the night on e 8 is still guarding
the g7 pawn very nicely but a couple
Bongo plays f6 immediately bishop moves
and now Knight to c7 as the position now
is pretty closed here there's really no
way this queen is ever coming to g4 do
for g5 so there's no no need for the
night to be guarding the g7 point
anymore
here Queen to d1 we have looked to the
8th preparing to put d5 we have rope to
d2 hoping to stop it and before pushing
King to h8 getting the King to to a
safer Square we have a three and now
rook the see it's still waiting before
pushing b5 bunch of to f2 and only now
Kabul Anka does push d5 we have it
captures Knight captures Bishop captures
rook captures and here Queen to g4 now
threatening Queen to g7 checkmate you
could capture but after capturing the
you're still not really really getting
anywhere with this move but ok after
work to d5 way of Queen to g4
immediately trying to avoid the exchange
of rooks and now Bishop to c5 Bishop to
f8 seems like a safer idea but
capablanca you know correctly assesses
the position that it's not not needed to
go back with the bishop we have rookie
to d1 and now Bishop captures on f2 with
check King captures and now doubling up
on the D file rook captures on d5 rook
captures on d5 rook captures and e5
Bishop captures on d5 and this is the
critical moment in the game here if you
look at this the the material is
completely the same and even Lasker has
an advantage on the Queen side three
points against - he has a night against
the bishop and the last rest pieces are
very active a couple 1 cos queen is
pretty much stuck here guarding the g7
pawn but there is one problem last
cursed King is also very vulnerable here
so before Lasker continues with any plan
he should move the King back King g1
King each one put the H bone
some bringing room for the king and only
then figure out how to do it because
last Christine is also kind of stuck
defending this pawn unless the night
goes back and then the night helps off
with the defense but as long as this
Queen betcha batteries on the G do porn
oh you're gonna have troubles trouble
you're not doing anything by pushing g3
then but I can even go the shop h1 and
threaten some mating ideas of his own
but you know definitely Kim Ji Won - h1
the best idea but here Alaska Alaska
tries to defend the B to pawn in an
active way he plays Queen to b4 and this
is you know sometimes sometimes
active/active is okay but too active is
not okay here the idea is of course if
you captured an Queen to a fate will be
checkmate but here he missed a very nice
idea by capablanca so I will invite you
to pause the video here and try to find
the idea
Alaska missed in this position so I will
give it a couple of seconds as usual for
those of you who found that
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who if you just
want to enjoy the show
here a cup of vodka played Queen to a7
but if you found Queen to b6 the idea is
completely the same Queen a7 check and
now you have a lot of problems as you
can see the G 1 square is no longer
available - that's why King G 1 to H 1
was necessary if you go something like
king he won then you allow Queen G 1
check and this is just terrible
this comes with check-in moves check
King moves you capture the peace and the
Queen of fate is nothing because the
bishop can go back and defend checkmate
another thing after this Queen to a7
check you realize now that you have to
go to a light square and they face this
Bishop to c4 check now in the game King
to e2 is play King to f1 would be even
worse but okay King f2 kingi - I will
push up the c4 check and now King back
to f3 and here kappa blanka could have
continued by this nice pawn sacrifice
efore and after King captures Queen a
check bringing the King even deeper but
here kappa blanka decided to go for a
different idea Queen a check immediately
King to have to and now Queen to d8
bringing the Queen all the way to d1 and
Quintus III as there's no more point in
keeping the Queen here even if the Queen
moves the bishop to g8 we'll always be
able to defend checkmate
so Queen C 3 we have Queen to d1 and now
Knight the g3 defending from Queen F 1
check
we have h6 creating some room for the
king b3 now captures captures and Bishop
captures on b3 nice to f1 we have Queen
to be won and now comes g4 Bishop to c4
attacking the knight we have 933 and now
Queen to h1 temporarily sacrificing upon
we have Knight captures but now of
course capablanca doesn't capture back
and allow Queen captures first Queen
captures on h2 with check King g1 queen
g1 check King moves queen F to check
King moves queen f1 check now connecting
with the night and c4 we have King
captures and now comes but B captures on
c4 and now couple one case of two points
and the a point is is a very strong
point but unfortunately it will not be
enough here Alaska did push a four we
have Queen to f4 check King moves and
now comes Queen captures on g4 Alaska
pushes the past pawn a5 Queen captures
on f5 Capablanca grabs yet another pawn
as he calculates correctly King to c1
getting out of check and now Queen to f2
we have Queen 23 preparing to push the
pawn and here King to h7 was played and
it was in this position that Emmanuel
asker resigned the game it seems like
regardless of blacks for extra points
white and simply push push the a pawn
and this will be fine for white
unfortunately not really after a six
Queen e1 check King moves and the now
comes a Queen d2 check King moves and
now c3 and now you can no longer push to
a 7 because C 2 is coming followed by c1
of course and after Queen to b3 white
now has to move away from the Queen he
cannot allow c2 and now after Queen to
e3 now you can either choose to push
the other points the victory you're
protecting the a seven square if
whatever pushes you will capture it but
one thing you can have to do and I hope
no one ever no one thought about doing
this because Queen d3 with ideas of
checking the king and winning the a sex
pawn will lose you the game because now
Queen the C two blocks check and now the
Queen is pinned because there's a king
on h7 here you have to exchange and now
it doesn't matter if you have four extra
points a seven a eight wins the game so
that would be pretty bad but okay
after King to h7 Alaska resigned again
and yet another victory goes to the
Cuban josé raúl capablanca taking a
great victory in round 15 a couple of
more runs to go till the end of this
tournament so hope you're enjoying it so
far and you know really enjoying this
incredible supremacy by josé raúl
capablanca
and this will be like we said in the
first video when we started this short
series one of the last examples of uh
non-soviet player crushing crushing
Soviets players so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with another
interesting video thank you